we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you can call
it three pm you can call it three a.m.
many of you do call at 3:00 a.m. i see
the timestamps on the voicemails let's
listen to this voicemail that came in i
was kind of concerned with your comments
on venezuela and then Maduro you're
being born in argentina you should know
too how american foreign policy has been
toward guatemala el salvador honduras
and to you to think that we're not
interested in venezuela soil after we
went into iraq but what we're interested
in guatemala and bananas and not to be
interested in Venezuelan oil is kind of
unrealistic okay so little fun fact that
voicemail you just heard was played for
the audience at nearly double speed huh
the individual notices couldn't even
tell it sounds almost like Matt met like
it's at normal speed that it was just a
notoriously slow talker which is
perfectly fine I mean with peace and
love tacos faster but it's quickly or
slowly go we're calling in what's that
louie gohmert calling here's the thing
whether or not the whether or not
American foreign Paul
interests are interested in Venezuelan
oil that is not a defense of the
repressive authoritarian regime of now
Nicolas Maduro formerly of Hugo Chavez
and this is where I think many on the
Left go wrong and I am not surprised to
hear that there are supposed liberals
progressives who don't like my take on
Venezuela which is that Maduro is an
absolute disaster is a completely
repressive regime and there's been
really good in you know a bunch of
people I was impressed pad I mentioned
yesterday that there's been some really
good investigative reporting from some
Argentinian media outlets that have been
watching and a bunch of people emailed
me they said can you send me some of the
links to the stuff you're talking about
because I'm interested in seeing how is
Venezuela being covered in other
countries really good investigative
reporting in Venezuela at the risk of
even arrests and interrogations for many
of these journalists and I followed up
with those people and I sent them the
stuff that I'd been watching no surprise
that some in our audience don't agree
my perspective on Venezuela those are
usually the same people that don't
believe Russia had anything to do with
the Trump campaign those are often the
same people that levy completely
irrational hateful critiques of Israel
in the context of the
israeli-palestinian conflict this is a
contingent of the left and and we saw
comments on YouTube as well Pat
criticizing me for my Venezuelan
thoughts on the bonus show today Cory
Booker gets involved in some possible
marijuana legalization legislation
efforts I guess we could call them
Luxembourg passes some interesting space
law and this is an issue that has been
interesting to me for several years and
Prince Philip has carried out his final
official engagement as royalty of
England
who'd be getting married to who what do
you mean engagement Oh engaged now
they're very very clever Pat going with
puns today yeah very interesting anyway
we will talk about all of those stories
and more on the bonus show that one
really threw me off there Pat if you
don't have access to the bonus show you
can get instant access by going to david
pakman.com slash membership you've got a
coupon code available it's I voted
seventeen gets you a 40% discount off of
membership and please please please keep
the patreon pledges coming in as little
as a dollar a month you can pledge at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
that's P 80 r EO n dot-com slash david
pakman show and August 12th major
membership offer going out to everybody
who subscribed to our newsletter you can
sign up for that on our website david
pakman.com